[Musique]
feu vert pour johnson
l'agencé européenne du médicament
c'est hier que le rapport b
fils risques liés à l'injection de son
vaccin reste positif comme pour
astrazeneca ils ont conclu que le sérum
johnson & johnson pouvait entraîner la
formation de thrombose atypique dans de
très rares cas
ah les vacances la mer les plages
paradisiaques bon mais que voilà ma dose
de vaccin visite vacances vaccin le
programme du gouvernement des maldives
pour attirer des touristes se faire
piquer au soleil l'idée à l'air tentante
pour certains internautes
je suis entièrement d'accord sur ces
histoires de chacun on veut jouer sa
partition et dans le contexte
juste une petite information la fête du
slip ça existe c'est au québec
et effectivement c'est pas c'est pas la
fête du slip est le site spoutnik triple
vous propose une formule tout inclus la
russie et une dose de vaccin spoutnik
vous avez sinon la formule vaccin à
dubaï pour 45000 euros proposés par cet
anglais pour les indiens un pack aller
retour aux états unis pour se faire
vacciner sur le week end et l'alaska qui
annoncent cet été le vaccin gratuit pour
les touristes dans ses aéroports
rien de tel que le coc vite touriste la
zone
le ménage au nord
selon angel rawal céline et natanya qui
se sont exprimées lors d'un live sur la
plateforme instagram tu veux pas forcer
la victoire tout en direct personne ici
pas pourtant pep un casting de talent la
production d'émissions faut en sorte de
pousser certains candidats à s'acharner
sur d'autres pour créer des séquences et
faire le buzz
[Musique]
d'accord avec toi mais choqué c'est nora
ce qu'elle nous avait dit quand il est
venu pour nous glisser avant qu'on
rentre dans la voiture elle ne la vit
avec eux les filles et anosy mot pour
mot sur l'exode ma mère c'est vrai elle
nous dit bombe alexis franchement les
mecs ils n'en peuvent plus ils sont à
l'hôtel ils vont exploser des tas
d'autres vous prendre une giclette stage
à l'habitat deux fois pardon genre de
bord des yeux qu'est ce qui se passe on
va faire quoi enfin où j'ai trois par
genre déjà je suis genre claustrophobe
des yeux donc du coup là je me dis c'est
pas possible j'ai commencé à stresser je
vais paniqué quand sortirait bien
[Musique]
transpire l'amour j'ai jamais vu ça de
ma vie quoi
ça pue l'amour sans trop beau l'amour de
cuques femmes l'amour sans bon j'ai
envie de dire voilà ton mari trois dans
la marque conneries happy days essayez
encore marc conneries mahoro
maroquinerie maroquinerie un barreau
conneries bah on n'y arrivera pas tant
pis on recommence autrement ah ben c'est
bien ton mari travaille dans le cuir
voilà c'est mieux c'est très très
suggestif couple et gastriques de salut
ça ne regarde que tu vois si je peux me
permettre
enfin marc table c'est quand même
tulasne et doux quand même le nom donné
à vue portemanteau tentation ya de la
drogue non oui pendant y'en à rennes la
liesse la drogue est mort il ya de la
drogue de l'alcool
il ya là la drogue la production le sait
elle est fournie par la production
elle est fournie par la police moi je
sais pas ce que c'est
qu'on l'annoncé il souhaite un grand
débat national sur la consommation de
drogue
mais dans sa tête il a déjà tranché il
faut briser ce tabou lancer un grand
débat national sur la consommation de
drogue et ses effets délétères
aucune légalisation du cannabis
n'interviendra d'ici la fin de son
mandat un message martelé par son
ministre de l'intérieur
mais cette histoire de cannabis moi je
trouve que le discours un peu bobo un
peu bourgeois de consommation et créatif
que souvent les beaux quartiers ont
alors ça peut être sympathique quand on
est dans le 16e arrondissement fumée du
chichon enfin life père de famille
qu'est toute seule et qu'elle explique à
ses enfants que la drogue c'est de la
merde
et bien c'est en santé publique et le
manière générale dans la vie sociale
c'est affreux voilà le cannabis c'est
affreux quand vous faites de la
légalisation vous contrôlez la
production vous contrôlez la vente la
réalité dans les pays européens où
justement il ya une réduction des
risques d'addiction une réduction des
maladies et notamment psychologiques
liés aux addictions la réduction des
trafics
ce sont des pays qui ont légalisé
je voulais ti votre revanche c'est oui
c'est un plat qui est mieux servi froid
[Musique]
parce
pas
électrique
prétendre le pour éteindre le feu
alors quand on se retrouve dans cette
situation il ne faut surtout pas
paniquer il faut couper des arrivées
d'électricité et de gaz faire évacuer la
cuisine et couvrir d'un linge humide la
source du feu ou se servir d'un
extincteur avant de contacter les
secours passaient là bernard cardon
marque une pause là bernard qui lui
raconte une histoire n'importe laquelle
celle qu à deauville de celui qui rentre
dans un verre et qui dit je voudrais un
jean et tout le monde dans le bord se
retourne en disant quelle taille quelle
taille
vous l'avez très bien elle vous a fait
rire charlot oui elle était drôle
beaucoup plus d'artistes dans sa région
et en sorte aussi attention attention
c'est jean michel blanquer requis est
aujourd'hui était en visite dans un
établissement scolaire qui restent
ouverts livry gargan pour accueillir les
enfants des personnes prix voilà des
personnes personnels prioritaires voilà
jean michel blanquer qui donne de sa
personne et qui joue avec cet enfant
une sorte de marelle non oui c'est ça
c'est ça c'est la marque les prochaines
semaines pour plaindre des millions de
français ça va être un peu la marelle on
va sauter d'un toit un autre de l'enfer
au paradis
alors moi c'était pendant le 2ème
couvre-feu confinement mais non c'est
plus on s'y perd un peu soulagé nous
avons maintenant
nous on fait des frais sur les murs de
la cellule pour voir en dordogne en a
trop beaucoup trop
j'avais peut-être ministre l'éducation
nationale qu'il fallait jouer à des
trucs là quand même ça ça me tient très
compliqué the spanish d'éducation
nationale j'essaie de retrouver d'autres
rebelles ou non je n'ai le général de
gaulle échoué
sauter danser chanter
à l'échelle
[Musique]